Okay Michael, you think you know the answer?
>> I do. So, if you hadn't said, yeah, up
until the very end I was thinking along, different lines. So,
if it's the case that we just want to choose, if,
if this f thing that is scoring is say, constant, then
choosing the best subset is easy, I can just choose
any subset I want. But you said then, it could actually
be arbitrary and it is unknown. So the only way
that I can know that I have the best scoring subset
is if I try all the subsets. And there's an exponential
number of subsets. So I'm going, I would go with exponential.
>> That's correct exactly what is the, the form of the exponential?
>> Oh, I want to say n choose m.
>> Yeah, but you don't actually even know what m is. N
choose m, n choose m is right and it gives you an exponential.
>> Good, alright. Thanks very much.
>> But, the other way is if you don't what
m is before you start. Then, it's just 2 to the n.
>> It's hard for me to imagine what that
means given that you made that part of the
input. If you mean just the best subset, then
yeah there's 2 to the n subsets. I agree.
>> So either one's fine because it gives
you the same answer. Sometimes we say, we
want half as many or, we want no more than half as many, and sometimes we
say we don't know what the best subset is. You figure it out. So this becomes
like a kind of clustering problem in its
own way except you don't know what k is.
But the other way of thinking about this is that of course this problem is hard,
of course it's exponential, it is effectively an
optimization problem over a set of arbitrary discreet variables.
>> That's how I was thinking about it
because we always seem to come back to that.
>> Right and in fact this problem is known to be
NP-hard. And it's exactly because you have to find all possible
subsets, so they match the three set. I will not prove
that but it does turn out that this is, in fact,
exactly the hard problem that you think it is. So given
this, and, and by the way, of course, of course this problem
is hard. Because if this problem weren't hard then most machine learning
would be pretty easy. So, it's not that big of a, it's
not that, it's not that surprising that the problem is difficult,
so the real question we have in front of us is given
that we've got yet another really difficult problem, in fact, a difficult
optimization problem, how might we go about tackling it? And it turns
out that there are two ways in general that people try to approach this problem.